Ich tauche ab in die Vergangenheit -
70 Jahre zurück ins Herz der Schweiz.
Tief in den Berg hinein,
auf der Suche nach seinem Geheimnis.
Es ist eine Reise
in die Zeit des 2. Weltkriegs,..
..in die Zeit des Reduits.
Damals wurde in der Schweiz ein
grosser Teil der Alpen ausgehöhlt..
..und mit bewaffneten Festungen
und Bunkern verbaut.
Während Jahrzehnten
waren die Anlagen geheim.
Wer sie verriet, kam ins Gefängnis.
Viele Bilder durfte man bis vor ein
paar Jahren nicht veröffentlichen.
Es ist die Zeit, als die Regierung
mitten in der Schweiz eine neue,..
..hypothetische Grenze gezogen hat.
Bis hier wäre das Reduit gegangen.
An der engsten Stelle des
Vierwaldstättersees bei Vitznau..
..hat man zur Befestigung der Grenze
eine Art Marine aufgebaut.
Weil das Militär am Anfang
noch keine Motorboote hatte,..
..musste man
auf private Boote zurückgreifen.
Diese hat man
mit leichten Waffen ausgerüstet.
Mit dem ersten Militärboot,
der Uri,..
..fahre ich mit Hansjakob Burckhardt
auf den See hinaus.
Er erklärt mir,
wie die Seesperre funktioniert hätte.
Die Absperre
bestand aus den Waffenstellungen,..
..in der Oberen Nas (links)
und der Unteren Nas (rechts).
Zusätzlich hat man noch,
als Unikat in der Schweiz,..
..eine schwimmende Seesperre
gemacht.
Die ging 1,2 km quere durch,
links von der Oberen Nas weg,..
..hier in diese Bucht.
Gegen was wäre das gedacht gewesen?
Wenn der Feind, also damals
die Deutsche Wehrmacht,..
..mit Booten über den See Richtung
Reduit gekommen wären.
Oder allenfalls
mit Wasserflugzeugen.
Tief im Fels versteckt und bis vor
ein paar Jahren streng geheim,..
..befindet sich
die bewaffnete Bunkeranlage,..
..die zu dieser Seebefestigung
gehörte, die Obere Nas.
Guten Tag, Herr Baumann.
Guten Tag.
Also, gehen wir ins Loch hinein.
Der Festungswart Alfred Baumann führt
mich ein ins Innenleben der Anlage.
Er zeigt mir, wie man mit der
gut getarnten Schiessscharte..
..den See verteidigt hätte.
Das ist ein Festungs-MG.
Damit kann man
mit oder ohne Sicht schiessen.
Mit Sicht heisst, dass man
durch das Zielfernrohr schaut ...
Und zwar so!
Wenn man den Feind sieht,
kann man ihn ins Visier nehmen.
Die befestigte Seesperre
Obere und Untere Nas -..
..eine einmalige Anlage
aus dem Krieg.
Heute braucht sie das Militär
nur noch zur Ausbildung.
1. September 1939.
Mit dem Überfall auf Polen bricht
Hitler endgültig den Frieden Europas.
Es ist der Anfang des 2. Weltkriegs.
Die Schweiz
bleibt weitgehend verschont.
Und trotzdem hat der Krieg,..
..zumindest die Generation
meiner Grosseltern stark geprägt.
Was man heute
in Archiven nachlesen kann,..
..war für sie
die gefürchtete Realität.
Die deutschen Truppen führten
einen regelrechten Blitzkrieg.
Frankreich kapitulierte schon 1940.
In Europa
blieb kein Stein auf dem anderen.
Die Schweizer Regierung verkündete
der Bevölkerung via Radio..
..ihr weiteres Vorgehen.
Bundespräsident Marcel Pilet-Golaz
hielt seine umstrittene Rede.
Die Schweizer Bevölkerung muss sich
der neuen Situation anpassen.
Aufhören zu jammern,
sondern anpacken.
Die Ereignisse überstürzen sich..
..und die Schweiz muss sich
diesem Rhythmus anpassen.
Nur so gibt es eine Perspektive
für das Land.
Seine Rede
kam beim Volk nicht gut an.
Geschichtsprofessor Jakob Tanner
von der Uni Zürich erklärt warum:
Diese Rede hatte eine
niederschmetternde Wirkung.
Viele verstanden sie so,
dass sie dachten,..
..die Regierung
sei nun weich geworden.
Nun sei die Hoffnungslosigkeit in
der politischen Spitze angekommen.
Mitten in diese resignierte
Politik kam einer, der dem Volk..
..den Glauben an die eigene Stärke
zurück gab: Henri Guisan.
Am 30. August 1939
wählte ihn die Bundesversammlung..
..zum General der Schweizer Armee.
Je le jure!
Und er fand die richtigen Worte:
Persönlich glaube ich nicht nur an
die Notwendigkeit und die Pflicht,..
..sondern auch an die wirksame
Möglichkeit uns zu verteidigen.
Verteidigen heisst,
nicht nur halten,..
..sondern sich
mit aller Kraft schlagen.
Sein Leben
so teuer wie möglich verkaufen.
Ein eindringlicher Appell.
Der General mutete dem Volk
ziemlich viel zu.
Der Plan,
den er dem Volk präsentierte,..
..war zwar nicht ganz neu,
aber tollkühn.
Der General propagierte
den Rückzug der Truppen ins Reduit.
Tief hinein in die Berge.
Das Innerste des Landes
wollte man verteidigen..
..mit dem Gotthard im Zentrum.
Ein Plan, den der General der Armee
und dem Volk plausibel machen musste.
Die Schweiz in den Alpen einbunkern -
eine verrückte Idee.
Aber General Guisan suchte sich
einen symbolträchtigen Ort aus,..
..um seine Botschaft
den engsten Vertrauten weiterzugeben.
Er versammelte die Armeespitze
auf dem Dampfschiff "Stadt Luzern"..
..und führte sie dem Rütli zu.
Fast 70 Jahre später
treffe ich hier..
..General Guisans Enkel,
Maurice Decoppet.
Der ehemalige Pilot beurteilt
die Strategie seines Grossvaters.
Wenn man sich
das heute vorstellt,..
..dass auf diesem Schiff die gesamte
Armeespitze versammelt war,..
..ist das fast unvorstellbar.
Ja, aber offenbar haben sie
eine Lageeinschätzung gemacht.
Sie kamen zum Schluss, dass
keine effektive Gefahr bestand,..
..dass ein Bomberschwadron
von Deutschland aus gestartet ist.
Ein gewagtes Unterfangen
Ihres Grossvaters.
Die Lage der Schweiz
war auch sehr schwierig.
Es war ein Risiko gegen ein anderes.
Für ihn war das
das kleinere Risiko,..
..als das Land
weiter in der Unsicherheit..
..über den Willen und der Kraft
der Armee zu lassen.
Rund 500 Offiziere,
vom Major aufwärts,..
..waren an diesem 25. Juli 1940
Richtung Rütli unterwegs.
Diskret bewacht von nur gerade
einem unbewaffneten Polizeiboot.
Längst nicht alle von der Armeespitze
standen hinter General Guisan.
Heute weiss man, dass viele Offiziere
mit den Nazis sympathisierten.
Sie wünschten sich
den Anschluss an Deutschland,..
..nicht den Rückzug ins Reduit.
Den Ort für seinen
folgenschweren Rapport..
..wählte Henri Guisan
nicht von ungefähr.
Das Rütli, seit jeher das Wahrzeichen
einer wehrhaften Schweiz,..
..unterstreicht
seine Widerstandsrede.
Hatte er ein Manuskript?
Ja, aber er hat nicht abgelesen.
Er sagte, dass sie hier
an einem historischen Ort stünden.
Das Gelände könne man verteidigen.
Wenn sie daran glauben, glaube das
auch die ganze Armee und das Volk.
Die Lage der Schweiz war zu
diesem Zeitpunkt tatsächlich prekär.
Die Bedrohung vom Ausland her
massiv und schwierig einzuschätzen.
Fast gleichzeitig mit der
Kapitulation von Frankreich..
..griff Italien in den Krieg ein.
Die unheilige Allianz
Hitler-Mussolini kam voll zum Tragen.
Das faschistische Italien ist durch
die geniale schöpferische Arbeit..
..eines Mannes
zu einem neuen Imperium geworden.
Sieg Benito Mussolini!
Wichtig ist,
dass unsere beiden grossen Völker,..
..die an Menschen die gewaltige und
wachsende Masse 115 Mio. betragen..
..zusammenstehen in einer einzigen
unerschütterlichen Entschlossenheit!
"Heil"-Rufe
In der Schweiz
schlug mit dem Rütli-Rapport..
..die Stunde der Festungstruppen.
Die Alpen wurden in einer
gigantischen Aktion ausgehöhlt.
Im Gebirge entstanden viele schwer
bewaffnete Bunker und Festungen,..
..die sich dem Gelände anpassen
und kaum zu sehen sind.
Eine Hand voll Soldaten,
eingeschlossen in den Bergen -..
..das wäre das Reduit gewesen.
Die Industrie im Mittelland und
die bevölkerungsreichen Städte,..
..wäre man im Notfall bereit gewesen,
dem Feind auszuliefern.
Aus heutiger Sicht
kaum nachvollziehbar.
Dazumal fand der Entschluss
des Generals eine breite Zustimmung.
Sie gingen ins Reduit zurück.
Das hiess aber nicht,
dass sie sich anpassten,..
..sondern, dass sie
Widerstand leisten wollten.
Ich besuche
in Niederurnen/GL Walter Rohr.
Er hat den Krieg miterlebt..
..und hat noch heute eine grosse
Bewunderung für General Guisan.
Warum fanden Sie ihn gut?
Er war sehr menschlich.
Er war kein Militärkopf.
Glauben Sie?
Ja. er war ein Romand.
Sind die anders?
Ja.
Er hatte den Kontakt zum Volk.
Man hat ihn akzeptiert.
Stellen Sie sich vor, es kommt
eines Tages einer und sagt ...
Sie haben sicher schon
vom "Rütli-Rapport" gehört.
Fanden Sie den Entscheid gut?
Um Widerstand zu leisten
gab es nichts anderes.
Wir hatten
keine Panzerabwehr - nichts.
Wir hatten nur 6 Praga Panzer.
Die wiegen nur 6 t. Das ist nichts.
Wir hatten zwar ein paar
Motor-Kanonen-Batterien.
Doch das hätte nicht viel genützt.
Aber man hätte das Volk geopfert.
Das hat man damals akzeptiert.
Es gab keine Opposition dagegen.
Man hat akzeptiert,
dass man sich zurückzog.
Walter Rohr leistete 1944 im Gotthard
bei den Festungstruppen Aktivdienst.
Er war damals gerade 20 Jahre alt und
kam gerade aus der Rekrutenschule.
Das war im Winter, im Dezember.
Ein Detachement
musste auf den Hospiz.
Dafür nahm man die sog. Hamburger.
Das sind Soldaten,..
..die zum ersten Mal einen WK oder
damals eben Aktivdienst leisteten.
Wir hatten dort oben 3,5 m Schnee.
Jeden Morgen mussten wir
die Geschütze ausgraben.
Schneeverwehungen haben sie
immer wieder zugedeckt.
Auf der Wache hat man es nur 30 Min.
ausgehalten, wegen der Kälte.
Wir fahren zusammen
Richtung Gotthard.
Zurück in die Gegend
und zu den Erinnerungen,..
..die den 85-Jährigen
bis heute prägen.
26 Tage lang war Walter Rohr
im Gotthardgebiet im Aktivdienst.
Später arbeitete er sich
hoch bis zum Feldweibel.
Hier ein Bild von ihm
als junger Soldat.
Oberhalb Airolo,
bei einer ehemaligen Festung,..
..treffen wir
einen der letzten Kommandanten,..
..der hier bis 1997 im Einsatz war.
Das Häuschen
ist als Rustico getarnt.
Es ist der Eingang zum
Artilleriewerk Foppa Grande.
Es ist das kleinste Werk
der Gotthardbefestigungen.
Eine Festung,
die auch Walter Rohr vertraut ist.
Das war das Wachtlokal.
Darin wurde
die Ausweiskontrolle gemacht.
Wenn jemand in das Werk wollte,
musste er seinen Ausweis zeigen.
In einem Kästchen lagerte
ein Ausweis mit einem Foto.
Erst mit dem durfte er hinein.
Das Artilleriewerk Foppa Grande
wurde 1939 ausgebaut..
..und mit Waffen nachgerüstet.
Eine 10,5 cm Stahlgranate, die man
mit dem Panzerturm verschossen hat.
Man brauchte nur ein Jahr,
um die Festung Foppa Grande zu bauen.
Sie war v.a. gedacht,
sich gegen Süden zu verteidigen,..
..gegen das faschistische Italien.
Nur 14 km von hier entfernt.
Die steilen, verschneiten Alpen..
..sah das Militär
als ureigenen Schweizer Vorteil an.
In waghalsigen Manövern übte man, das
schwierige Gelände zu verteidigen.
Guisans Strategie: Den Eintrittspreis
mit Hilfe des alpinen Geländes..
..so hoch wie möglich anzusetzen.
Nicht zuletzt, weil die Deutschen..
..das flache und neutrale Holland
sehr schnell einnahmen.
Wie es war, während Wochen in diesen
Festungen eingebunkert zu sein,..
..kann ich mir heute
kaum mehr vorstellen.
Und wenn, stelle ich es mir schlimm
vor und möchte es nicht ausprobieren.
Während dem Krieg lebten rund
200 Männer während Wochen hier drin.
Ohne grossen Kontakt zu Familie,
Freunden und ohne Tageslicht.
Meine beiden Begleiter erklären mir,
warum sie glauben,..
..dass die Schweiz
vom Krieg verschont blieb.
Ein Grund war sicher die Arme, die
an der Grenze Widerstand leistete.
Dann wären
die Industrieanlagen im Mittelland..
..dem Feind
beschädigt in die Hände gefallen.
Alle waren waren darauf vorbereitet,
sie unbrauchbar zu machen.
Dann hätte sich der Feind
durch die Voralpen kämpfen müssen.
Es gab ein Sprengobjekt
nach dem anderen.
Wenn er dann wirklich
auf den Gotthard gekommen wäre,..
..hätte man den Tunnel
und die Strasse sprengen können,..
..damit sie nicht mehr
passierbar gewesen wären.
Der Gotthard war ein Symbol.
Ich glaube, dass uns die Deutschen
darum nicht überfielen.
Sie wussten, dass er
in die Luft fliegen würde.
Wie meinen Sie in die Luft geflogen?
Der Tunnel.
Und damit wäre die
Nord-Süd-Verbindung kaputt gewesen.
Sie hätten nichts gewonnen.
Sie hätten nur viele Truppen
einsetzen müssen.
Die Gegenleistung war nichts.
Das war die Strategie
des hohen Eintrittspreises.
Die hatten wir nicht nur damals,
sondern auch später noch.
Das ist alles hypothetisch.
Glauben Sie, wenn es
wirklich so weit gekommen wäre,..
..dass das eine nützliche
Abwehrstrategie gewesen wäre?
Was hätte man sonst machen sollen?
Es geht nicht um die Alternative,
sondern darum, ob das geklappt hätte?
Hören Sie zu!
Es ging darum ...
Auch später im Kalten Krieg.
Im Sicherheitsbericht
aus dem Jahre 1973 steht,..
..dass ein gewisser Teil des
Staatsgebietes gehalten werden muss.
Das wären hier
die Felsen am Gotthard?
Einen gewissen Teil halten..
..und das kann man dort,
wo man geländestark ist.
Und das ist eben im Gebirgsraum.
Das drängt sich fast auf.
Also, dann hätten man diesen Teil
vielleicht halten können.
Aber den grossen Rest nicht.
Es ging darum,
einen gewissen Teil zu halten.
Gestein und Felsen, vom Gotthard bis
zum Simplon, vom Nufenen bis Sargans.
Im Extremfall wäre das bei einem
deutschen Angriff übriggeblieben.
Frauen und Kinder, Eltern und Freunde
hätte man in den Städten..
..praktisch schutzlos zurückgelassen.
Gigantische Bunkeranlagen in den
Bergen, riesige Festungsbauten,..
..schwer bewaffnet und
gut geschützt - das ist das Reduit.
Wenn ich mir alles bis ins Detail
überlege, fällt es mir schwer,..
..die Reduit-Idee bis zur letzten
Konsequenz nachzuvollziehen.
Ihre Familie
wäre auch ausgeliefert gewesen.
Ich habe nie ein Gejammer
von der Mutter gehört.
Auch nicht vom Vater.
Er musste auch immer
Ablösung machen.
Was hier drinnen geschah, was Sie
machten, war alles geheim.
Das hat man niemandem erzählt?
Man durfte nicht einmal genau sagen,
wo man war.
Was haben Sie zu Hause erzählt?
Ich war damals noch ledig.
Mein Vater war auch in der Festung.
Wir wussten schon, was wir sagen
durften und was nicht.
Ihrem Vater haben Sie
auch nichts gesagt?
Doch, er wusste, wo ich war.
Aber die Mutter wusste nicht,
wo Sie waren?
Doch, sie wusste es.
Das konnte man nicht geheim halten.
Wie war es bei Ihnen, Herr Rauch?
Haben Sie es Ihrer Frau gesagt?
Nein.
Sie wusste, dass ich im Raum
Andermatt oder Airolo war.
Aber nicht genau wo.
Das natürlich nicht.
Man sagte nur, man sei im Gotthard.
Im Aktivdienst
wurde man sogar darum beneidet,..
..dass man im Gotthard Dienst
machen durfte.
Im Panzerturm
kommen die beiden ins Schwärmen.
Eine Armee,
die sich im Gebirge verschanzt..
..und von dort aus das Vaterland
verteidigen will,..
..geschrumpft
auf ein kleines Kerngebiet.
Ob so etwas mit den heutigen
möglichen Bedrohungslagen..
..noch denkbar wäre,
das ist die Frage.
Die Antwort
bekomme ich im Bundeshaus,..
..beim obersten Chef des Militärs,
bei Bundesrat Ueli Maurer.
Er verkündete bei Amtsantritt,
er wolle die beste Armee der Welt.
Er erläuterte mir,
wie er zum Reduit steht.
Das Reduit ist ja
nicht einfach eine Idee.
Es ist eine Verstärkung entlang
des Geländes, in dem man stark ist.
Wir würden
auch heute noch versuchen,..
..uns abzuschotten oder
eine Verteidigungslinie aufzubauen.
Das Reduit ist eine natürliche Ab-
schottung mit den Bergen und Alpen.
Wenn Sie
jemanden aufhalten wollen,..
..gehen Sie nicht auf die Wiese,
wo alle durchfahren,..
..sondern dorthin,
wo er sicher durch muss.
Das wusste schon
Wilhelm Tell bei Gessler.
Letztendlich hätte man
das ganze Mittelland preisgegeben.
Das wäre
ein sehr hoher Preis gewesen.
Damals gab der Reduit-Gedanke
das Vertrauen..
..in den Glauben an die eigene
Verteidigungsfähigkeit zurück.
Darum war das Reduit
auch ein psychologischer Aspekt.
Viele Leute haben heute das Gefühl,
wir hätten es damals geschafft.
Hätte man es geschafft?
Davon bin ich überzeugt.
Die Überzeugung des Bundesrats..
..bezüglich der eigenen
Wehrhaftigkeit ist klar und deutlich.
Ich vermute, der Historiker wird
damit nicht ganz einverstanden sein.
Was hat uns aus Ihrer Sicht
vor dem Krieg verschont?
Die Schweiz hätte als demokratischer
Kleinstaat nicht überlebt,..
..wenn die Alliierten
den Krieg nicht gewonnen hätten.
Die Schweiz verdankt ihr Überleben
der Kriegsführung der Alliierten.
Das nahm man in der Schweiz
wenig zur Kenntnis.
Man ging davon aus,..
..dass die eigene Armee
diese Abschreckungswirkung hatte.
Die deutschen Angriffsplaner,
die Pläne ausgearbeitet haben,..
..waren von der Schweizer Armee
nicht überzeugt.
Ich habe hier den Plan Zimmermann
vom 4. Oktober 1940.
In dieser Zeit hatte Deutschland
noch freie Kapazitäten.
Hier steht, dass sich
die Schweizer Soldaten stark wehren.
Sie seien
in der Kriegsführung geübt,..
..obwohl der Krieg
an der Schweiz vorbeigeht.
Sie hätten
einen zähen Widerstandsgeist.
Am Schluss steht: "Es erscheint
zweifelhaft, ob sich die Schweiz..
..einem gemeinsamen militärischen
Vorgehen Deutschlands und Italiens..
..gegenüber zum Kampf stellen wird."
Die Schweiz setzte nach dem Rütli-
rapport nicht nur auf die Armee,..
..sondern v.a. auf die Wirtschaft.
Nach dem Reduit-Befehl..
..verkleinerte General Guisan die
Armee von 450'000 auf 150'000 Mann.
Wer keinen Dienst leistete,
war eine willkommene Arbeitskraft.
Die Wirtschaft
konnte mit den Leuten,..
..die an die Arbeitsplätze
zurückkamen,..
..ihre Produktion wieder aufnehmen.
Die Schweiz
machte am 9. August 1940..
..mit Deutschland
einen Wirtschaftsvertrag.
Dieser Vertrag gewährleistete
in der Schweiz die Importe.
So konnte man
eine wirtschaftliche Kooperation..
..mit Deutschland
und anderen Ländern aufnehmen.
Deutschland war aber
das wichtigste Abnehmerland..
..für Waffen, Werkzeugmaschinen
und kriegswichtige Güter.
General Guisan
rückte den Zusammenhang..
..nicht so stark in den Vordergrund.
Er schlug 3 Wochen
nach dem Rütli-Rapport vor,..
..eine Sonderbotschaft
nach Berlin zu schicken.
Sie hätte die
schweizerische Wirtschaftsleistung..
..nach Deutschland ankurbeln müssen.
Der Bundesrat lehnte dies ab.
General Guisan
verfolgte eine Doppelstrategie:
..das Volk mit einer zündenden Idee,
dem Reduit, psychologisch stärken..
..und gleichzeitig wirtschaftlich
mit den Aussenmächten kooperieren,..
..v.a. mit Nazi-Deutschland.
Ein Nachmittag im Frühling 2009:
In Horgen, in der Albisstube
des Restaurants Schinzenhof,..
..treffen sich die Veteranen
der Gotthard-Festungstruppe..
..aus dem Aktivdienst
zur Kompanie-Tagung.
Hier treffe ich auch wieder
Walter Rohr und Andrea Rauch.
Der Wind pfiff am Helm vorbei.
Die Schweiz hätte sich wehren können.
Ich hätte mich
bis auf den letzten Zahn gewehrt.
Ich machte noch Ortswehr.
Ich fasste mit 15 Jahren ein Gewehr.
Ich habe
48 Schüsse Munition gefasst.
Ausserdem eine Windjacke
und einen Stahlhelm.
Ein Oberst hat uns im Wald
zur Verteidigung ausgebildet.
Man hatte den Willen,
das Vaterland zu verteidigen.
Es hiess: "Wer nicht schweigen kann,
schadet der Heimat."
Alle Wegweiser waren demontiert.
Es gab keinen Wegweiser mehr
auf der Strasse,..
..damit die deutsche Wehrmacht
den Weg nicht findet.
Man durfte nichts erzählen.
Wem haben Sie es denn erzählt?
Niemandem.
Gar niemandem?
Das ging auch niemanden etwas an.
Ihrem Schatz?
Eine Weile lang musste man
die Achselnummer wegnehmen,..
..damit niemand sah,
wo man eingeteilt war.
Ich hatte damals einen Schatz
in Luzern. Schon wieder ein Schatz!
Wir waren spazieren,
als uns ein Offizier entgegen kam.
Wenn man jemanden am Arm hat,
grüsst man nicht gern.
Ich schaute also weg. Dann sagte er:
"Wo sind Sie eingeteilt?"
Ich sagte:
"Ich darf es nicht sagen."
Dann musste er mich laufen lassen.
Er konnte nichts tun.
Nur ein Querulant reichte,
damit alles kaputt war.
Das gab es schon, oder?
Entweder hat man ihn verpfiffen oder
bei den Offizieren angeschwärzt,..
..wenn er sich
nicht richtig verhalten hat.
Es stellte sich heraus,..
..dass er heimlich
in der nationalen Front mitmachte.
Das haben Sie erlebt?
Ja, das habe ich erlebt.
Manchmal gab es Ärger
mit den Offizieren.
Es lief nicht immer alles glänzend.
Aber man denkt
irgendwie nur an das Schöne.
Man hatte es untereinander gut.
Das Schlimme vergisst man.
Wir brauchten das Gelände
zur Verteidigung.
Es kam nicht in Frage,
kampflos aufzugeben.
Das stand nie zur Diskussion.
Es gab einen Spruch der Deutschen.
"Die Schweiz, das Stachelschwein,
das nehmen wir im Heimweg ein."
Aber es fand nicht statt.
Gottlob, oder?
Ja, Gottlob.
Direkt an der Bahnlinie Gotthard
führten ja Kohlenwege durch.
Dazwischen gab es Eisenbahnwagen,..
..bei denen die Federn
stark gebogen runter hingen.
Unten drin war Munition.
Es macht nur "bubum, bubum!"
Dort, wo es nur Kohle hatte,
machte es: "dädä, dädä!"
Schweres Material wurde
nach Italien hin- und her geschoben.
Das ist der eigentliche Trumpf
der Schweiz,..
..die so wichtige
Nord-Süd-Verbindung.
Sie garantiert dem Land
den Güteraustausch,..
..aber natürlich auch die Verbindung
zwischen Deutschland und Italien.
Die wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit
der Schweiz mit Deutschland..
..während der Kriegsjahre
blieb lange weitgehend unerforscht.
Erst Mitte der 90er-Jahre
setzte das Parlament..
..auf internationalen Druck
die sog. Bergier-Kommission ein.
Sie hätte die Rolle der Schweiz
im 2. Weltkrieg aufarbeiten sollen.
2002 erschien
der Bergier-Schlussbericht:
Die Schweiz musste sich
zum ersten Mal Themen wie Raubgold,..
..nachrichtenlosen Vermögen,
wirtschaftlicher Kooperation..
..mit Deutschland und einer umstrit-
tenen Flüchtlingspolitik stellen.
Wie ist das bei Ihnen angekommen?
Oder was sagen Sie dazu?
Die Bergier-Kommission
erhob ja den Vorwurf,..
..man habe sich
den Deutschen untergeordnet.
Man muss sich vorstellen:
Wir brauchten ja auch Arbeit.
Wenn wir Rohstoffe brauchten, waren
wir auf Deutschland angewiesen.
Viele Dinge, die in dieser Bergier-
Kommission angeprangert werden,..
..wie z.B. Waffenlieferungen
nach Deutschland,..
..waren nach der Haager-Konvention
in Ordnung.
Von Privaten, nur das Land
durfte nichts liefern.
Das Positive kommt
zu wenig zum Ausdruck,..
..die Haltung der Bevölkerung.
Sie können nicht begreifen,
dass gewisse Dinge so schlimm waren.
Was war denn so schlimm?
Die ganze Situation.
Wir waren ja in der 2. Mobilmachung
wie auf Nadeln.
"Kommt er, oder kommt er nicht?"
Wir wussten nie,
ob der Teufel ganz los ist.
Man konnte
nicht mehr richtig schlafen.
Man war aufgeregt
und alle waren nervös.
Eine solche Situation kann man sich
heute nicht mehr vorstellen.
Gibt es einen Punkt
in diesem Bericht,..
..welcher der Wahrheit entspricht?
Ich habe den Bericht nicht gelesen.
Es sind ja ca. 12'000 Seiten.
Die Behandlung der Juden
war sicher nicht in Ordnung.
Aber es gab die Konferenz von Evian.
Die Schweiz
nahm jüdische Flüchtlinge auf,..
..die aber
wieder weiterreisen mussten.
Alle schreiten:
"Kommt nicht in Frage!"
Nur Chile sagte:
"Wir nehmen sie, aber nur Bauern."
Bei den Juden gab es keine Bauern.
Was machen wir,
wenn wir alle reinlassen?
Wie viele waren das,
die gekommen wären?
Die Bevölkerung
hätte sich verdoppelt.
Auch Historiker Jakob Tanner arbei-
tete an diesem Bergier-Bericht mit.
Die Kritik ist auch
ganz direkt an ihn gerichtet.
Ich habe wenig Verständnis..
..für eine pauschale Ablehnung
von Forschungsergebnissen..
..und die Berufung auf einen Mythos,
der einem Lebenssinn stiftete.
Ich habe als Historiker
eine andere Funktion,..
..nämlich eine kritische Funktion.
Ich muss versuchen, Forschungs-
ergebnisse plausibel zu machen.
Aber ich kann nicht sagen:
"Genau so ist es gewesen."
Wenn ich das so formuliere,
heisst das,..
..dass die Frage sich nach
dem Krieg hätten stellen müssen.
Nach der Befreiung
durch die Alliierten..
..hätte die Schweiz sagen müssen:
"Wir sind durchgekommen,
aber mit moralisch hohen Kosten."
Wir sind von diesen
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen abhängig.
Man hatte wenig Spielraum,
muss aber gleichzeitig sagen:
Man kaufte Deutschland
über eine Milliarde Raubgold ab.
Das war die Bereitschaft,
eine eingespielte Kooperation..
..einfach mal "business-as-
usual"-mässig weiterzuführen.
Bei der Flüchtlingspolitik
hätte es Alternativen gegeben.
Die Schweiz
war nicht das volle Boot,..
..das sich selber als
Entlastungsargument darstellte.
Bei den nachrichtenlosen Vermögen
hätte man sich..
..während des Krieges überlegen
können, wie man danach damit umgeht.
Bis in den 90er-Jahren,
bis zum Ende des Kalten Krieges,..
..hielt die Schweiz
an ihrer Verbunkerungsstrategie fest.
Sie pflegte ihre Igelmentalität..
..und setzte auf die geheimen
Festungen in den Bergen.
Auf dem Weg in den Kanton Uri,
nach Amsteg:
Tief im Fels versteckt
unter der Zwing Uri..
..und bis vor ein paar Jahren geheim,
ist der Brindlistollen.
Der ehemalige Bundesratsbunker
aus dem 2. Weltkrieg ist der erste,..
..den es in der Schweiz je gab.
Nur einmal war der Bundesrat
wirklich dort,..
..am 10. November 1945,
kurz nach dem Krieg.
Elisabeth Tresch ist die Tochter
dieses Amsteger Wirts,..
..der für die Gesellschaft aus Bern
kochte.
Er und sein Personal
brachten das Essen in den Bunker.
Die Menüs weiss ich nicht mehr.
Ich nehme an,
dass es damals einen Braten gab.
Es gab nur weibliches Personal.
Mein Vater musste vorgängig angeben,
wer es war.
Man hat etwas filtriert.
Nachträglich hiess es, dass es
ein ziemlich fröhliches Fest war.
2 Bundesräte hätten noch
beim Abtrocknen geholfen.
Die beiden, an die ich mich noch gut
erinnern kann, waren lustig.
Sie waren gesangsfreudig.
Ich denke, nach einem "Kaffee mit"
hätte das stimmen können.
Nicht weit weg
vom Wirtshaus in Amsteg ist er,..
..der ehemalige Bundesratsbunker.
Seit 1997 gehört er
dem Einheimischen Dolf Wipfli.
Er zeigt mir einen Teil der Anlage.
Er machte aus dem Bunker
einen riesigen Tresor..
..und baute im Berg
ein verschwiegenes Geschäft..
..für Sicherheitsdienstleistungen auf
- Swiss Data Safe.
Mit von der Partie
ist Maurice Lovisa.
Der Architekt inventarisierte
im Auftrag des Bundes..
..alle militärischen Festungsanlagen.
Ist das ein Originaleingang
des Stollens?
Ja, das wurde so gebaut.
Warum haben sie das so gelassen?
Das ist einer der wenigen Zugänge,
die wir haben.
Wenn wir es aus geschäftstechnischen
Gründen nicht ändern müssen,..
..lassen wir es so.
Die Dimensionen des Bunkers
sind gewaltig.
Im Ernstfall hätten hier
neben den 7 Bundesräten..
..noch 372 Menschen Platz gehabt,
dazu 123 Autos und 13 Lastwagen.
Das Besondere am Bundesratsbunker
offenbart sich..
..in der Mitte der Kaverne -
eine 2. komplett andere Konstruktion.
Wir sind jetzt in der Kaverne.
Hinter diesen Wänden versteckt sich
eine grosse Seltenheit,..
..eine 2-stöckige Holzkonstruktion.
Das ist sehr speziell
und besonders in der Schweiz.
Heimelig wie in einem Chalet
ist es hier drin.
Das Gefühl des Bunkers
geht komplett verloren.
Nur die Fenster fehlen. Es ist wie
in einer romantischen Skilagerhütte.
General Guisan
war im Berner Oberland..
..und der Bundesrat
im Urserental oder im Kanton Uri.
Das ist die erste Besonderheit.
Dass man getrennt gewesen wäre?
Ja, das hätte man getrennt.
Die innere Konstruktion
des Chalets ist einmalig.
Und dann gibt es
eine ungenutzte Anlage.
Man kann den Denkmalschutz mit der
Erhaltung der Ziele erheischen.
Wussten Sie, dass das
der Bundesratsbunker ist?
Nein, das wusste eigentlich niemand.
Das wurde erst bekannt
beim Prozess des Verkaufs.
Aber in einem Dorf
wird ja viel geredet.
Das war wirklich unbekannt.
Ich weiss es nicht genau,
aber man hört solche Dinge.
Man hört?
Ja, man hört auch andere Dinge.
Zum Beispiel?
Die Anlage hat einen Tresorraum,
der bis ca. 1995..
..von der Schweizerischen
Nationalbank gebraucht wurde.
Man weiss nicht genau, was drin war.
Man sagt, es seien Papiere gewesen.
Haben Sie nachgefragt?
Ja, wir waren ja neugierig,
aber Antworten gab es keine.
Sie selber sind ja ähnlich.
Ja, wir sind zwar
neugierig und fragen,..
..aber selber
geben wir wenig Auskunft.
Einen Teil des Bunkers
liess Dolf Wipfli wie früher..
..und empfängt in diesen Räumen
seine Gäste.
Den Rest liess er
hochmodern ausbauen..
..und führt die Tradition
des verschwiegenen Geschäfts weiter.
Hinter diesen Panzertüren
bunkert er verschiedene Sachen..
..im Wert von Milliarden sicher ein:
..Kunst, Schmuck, sensible Daten
von Banken und Versicherungen.
Die Übersicht, wie viele Bunker
und Festungen heute umgebaut,..
..für die Öffentlichkeit zugänglich
oder immer noch geheim sind,..
..gibts im Büro
des "Bunkerologen" Maurice Lovisa.
Versteckt am Gotthard
wurde eine grössere Festung..
..im 2. Weltkrieg gebaut,
Sasso da Pigna.
Sie war geheim und
man konnte sie nicht besuchen.
Ich habe sie
ein paar Jahre später gesehen.
Ich war ein wenig enttäuscht.
Darum sollte man
den Mythos nicht zerstören.
Er ist viel wichtiger
als die Realität.
Es ist also wichtiger,
dass gewisse Dinge geheim bleiben.
Nicht wegen politischen Aspekten,..
..aber wegen dem psychologischen
Bewusstsein des Menschen.
Aber jetzt wissen Sie ja alles.
Nicht alles, aber viel.
Was wissen Sie noch nicht?
Was weiss ich nicht? Wahrscheinlich
die geheimsten Objekte.
So genau wissen Sie es nicht?
Vielleicht.
Wie meinen Sie das?
Es gibt sehr geheime Objekte,..
..die nur wenige Leute kennen
und wissen, wo sie sind.
Gibt es Objekte,
die man Ihnen vorenthält?
Ich kenne eigentlich alle,
aber vielleicht gibt es einige,..
..die so gut versteckt sind, dass
fast niemand weiss, wo sie sind.
Es gibt eine Festung, die noch
nicht öffentlich zugänglich ist.
Es ist die sog. ...
Piepston
Ja.
Was wissen Sie darüber?
Es ist eine Anlage im Kanton Uri.
Sie ist wie gesagt
noch nicht öffentlich zugänglich.
Darum darf ich nichts sagen.
Nicht mal den Namen?
Piepston
Was ist dort drin?
Ich habe ein Verpflichtungsabkommen
mit dem VBS.
Ich kann sagen,
wir haben das studiert.
Es gibt interessante Aspekte.
Bestimmte Objekte
interessieren den Bund.
Sie sind
noch nicht entklassifiziert.
Darum müssen wir noch schweigen.
Über gewisse Objekte
wird aber immer noch geschwiegen,..
..auch wenn sie die Armee
heute oft zivil nutzt.
Die Armee hat sensitive Materialien.
Wir haben Vorräte. Tamiflu
wird z.B. bei der Armee gelagert.
Für gewisse Lagermöglichkeiten
machen gesicherte Orte Sinn.
Darum werden wir dort
auch in Zukunft Vorräte lagern,..
..aber nicht mit dem Gedanken
des 2. Weltkriegs.
Tamiflu ist also in einer Festung.
Ich weiss nicht wo,
aber Gold hätten wir ja auch.
Das sind geniale, teure Anlagen.
Was unsere Vorfahren an
technischen Einrichtungen bauten,..
..sind Kunstwerke.
Man müsste sie
unter Heimatschutz stellen.
Sicher werden auch einige
unter Schutz gestellt.
Das kostet bloss viel.
Das ist das Problem.
Wären keine Kosten da,
sollten wir alle in Betrieb halten.
Wir können es uns nicht leisten.
Noch zu einer anderen Festung:
Piepston
Sagt ihnen das etwas?
Ja.
Ist die noch geheim?
Wenn Sie sie kennen,
ist sie nur noch teilweise geheim.
Von aussen gesehen
kennt man ja viele Festungen.
Aber man weiss nicht,
wie viele Leute drin sitzen,..
..mit welchen Waffen man
wohin schiessen kann usw.
Die Festung lässt mir keine Ruhe.
Seit ich mich
mit diesem Thema beschäftige,..
..geistert der Name
Piepston   herum.
Erst hiess es, wir könnten als erstes
Filmteam in dieser Festung filmen.
Später kam der Bescheid, wir dürften
höchstens von der "TW" reden.
Die Festung wurde
je länger, je geheimer.
Am Schluss hiess es: Darin filmen
sei absolut ausgeschlossen.
In der Nähe der berühmten Teufels-
brücke, in der Schöllenenschlucht,..
..sehe ich sie nun
zumindest von aussen.
Fenster im Berg deuten darauf hin,..
..dass dahinter versteckt tatsächlich
eine riesige Festung sein muss.
Aber vielleicht ist es doch so:
Wegen dem Mythos müssen
gewisse Dinge geheim bleiben.
Der Gotthard will offensichtlich noch
nicht alle Geheimnisse preisgeben.